You know what's the biggest fucking slap in the face?
Like, in a girl female friendship,
the biggest fucking bitch can't move
is when you approach another woman with respect. Like, hey, beautiful
game. Recognized game.
Takes one to know one queen.
I tip my crown to your crown,
and you try to put them onto some information,
like your skirt is lifted up in the back,
or that man you're dating is.
And this bitch is gonna turn around
and slap you in the fucking face like,
oh, bitch,
who the fuck are you, bitch?
I got your man,
bitch, you wish you had this dress, bitch. Oh,
that is a special level of contemporary.
Ugh.
Have a great day.
Have the day you deserve.